okay for people joining this livestream
we are talking about neuron that design
for from language I am sick today so I'm
a bit subdued but we'll see how this
goes
alright so we've got several different
things multi output net encoder
okay so yeah we should probably start by
by this
so if I can summarize a program
currently encoder can take only one
input and one output same thing for
decoder and in many case we would need
incorrect with several output for
example it has two processing going on
on the same string let's say right now
you would need to do you know you need
to do to encoder and you will need to
write so I know my car is Association
into the encoder I'll have a producing
Association
so this is the purpose for now you can
put your link unless you should't shown
in so you can have multi input encoders
but in the framework for now you cannot
have several output okay fine but the
point is that those outputs have to be
connected to different tentacles of the
neural net that is that is the tricky
part yes a point here because the way
the framework was designed the encoder
is the property of the port is not
something that you connect to a port so
the whole the whole idea of having one
encoder connected to multiple ports is
already a change in the framework it's
not one of our one of our local kids or
is that just a random kid was the
documentation example it's the
documentation kit okay yeah just
wondering I try to keep track and
fast-forward with different people's
children but anyway the UM
okay so what's the proposal here so this
part is how to to create the net encoder
and the decoder so actually it will be
through the net encoder function which
is the way to do some custom things so
the generalization is like that normally
the sole argument is just size and now
it's an association of size and then the
function also has to be something that
we chose yes oh hold on just just show
me roughly what this is supposed to look
like in the end so this is an encoder
that has multiple that is going to
output multiple feature 1 and feature
two correct yes
yeah okay so show me how it hooks up to
the rest of the neural net framework
constriction that's the next error it's
the next step with a big warning sign
yeah because we yeah we had several
brainstorming to find a good design and
it was it's it's a tricky to pick let's
say okay to propose oh if you go up a
little bit yeah this is the last two
this last two Nate graph that's a two
proposal so the first one you see that
the the third argument on that graph is
a greedy a third argument by the way net
graph doesn't have a third argument it
was always a you know sort of option to
to specify the encoder and decoder and
so now you see this sort of option as
this extra rule your foo good will
change color and then an extra rule that
just tell you know the name of the sort
of output port of the encoder that you
can use to connect in the in the graph
connectivity rules
okay hold on so
this net Porter feature one that is the
standard use of net Porter's that
correct or is that not correct
so that's a network that's a labeled net
port that arrow one means what means
it's going to the index one inside this
just like this net graph yes
what does this mean I stole you
connected in the first and the second
layer to discern which is cutting the
tail and then this goes to the an output
port called net output one okay all
right okay so now what is this you have
the net graph is on the top edge respond
to this okay alright so what is this now
this blue arrow whatever so this is to
say that the input of the net we will be
n does a key fool when you call the net
and two outputs on the encoder will go
to tentacles feature one in future two
of the net worth sorry so in the end
this net Goff is going to be called with
an association that contains a foo in a
bar is that correct yes I notice that I
don't some it this was supposed to deal
with the fact that it has multiple
inputs right so why isn't every wife
there named foo why do we care about
that name
so the idea is that when you attach a
multi-part encoder you change the number
of the input parts of the network in
this case the bear network has two parts
they're called feature one in features
two but we want to attach a multi output
encoder to this network that it takes
one output and routes it and out one end
got one input sorry sorry takes one
input and produces two outputs so why do
we have to name that input we don't
necessarily have to name it right well
this is for consistency like all
networks so far
even with one input have named inputs
and in general because if you have
another one you know all right fine fine
but this this thing here in general
could have multiple things so this this
here probably most naturally as an
association since it's already sort of
options we just you know you can keep
going it's a full bar input 1 input to
output 1 output 2 it's var argh but
that's horrible this is how it has been
now sorry I understand the third
argument is the input the fourth
argument is the output is no there's no
third argument of fourth argument it's
all options options of what type what
what do the options mean basically every
port is is an option because you are
basically what you're doing here I mean
up to now what you were doing here in
that graph was basically saying
something about that specific port so
for example I think that shine
Association is like it should not be
random options because they may have
other options to net graph about you
know running things on GPUs or this or
that or the other I've no idea some
advisory stuff about something I don't
think that should I think that should be
in an association
all of these all of this kind of
annotation about what the various ports
mean input and output ports should be in
an association here that's just a small
point okay
now the definition of multi-encoder that
is a function that takes one input and
returns two outputs is that correct yes
yes does it take the input as just a
naked expression or does it take it as
an association it depends on how you
write it can be whatever it can be
anything okay but but its output is an
association where this is the structure
of the Association is that correct yes
yes mmm yes if you stand alone then yes
it produces an association whose keys
are the name of the output parts of the
encoder and whose values are numerical I
understand that so this is essentially
the key the key pattern the key yes
sequence for the encoder for the output
from the encoder yeah then what if you
attach it to a network on the other hand
you lose that that's the notion like it
just routes the arrays to the correct
parts of the network I understand so the
encoder if you ran the encoder
standalone it would produce some
Association if you do it in the context
of the network it will do something more
efficient explicitly generate the the
Association okay okay so this then is
those are the elements of the network
that's the connectivity of the network
and this is an annotation describing the
inputs and outputs of the network
correct yes it's really both because
also the second argument describes the
inputs and outputs that's addressing of
the inputs and the outputs if you wants
no it does not describe the inputs and
the outputs yes you see the notes and
the outputs but look this is not a I
mean you're saying that you could in
principle insert
directly into feature 1 is that correct
yes if the network is bare and doesn't
have any encoder you just remove the
fool who goes to something embargoes to
something that's a perfectly meaningful
rather no no no no no I'm asking if you
have this in this form right you have
this net graph and I then try to feed
data to this net graph feeding it
feature one arrow whatever okay up to
now in the past in which we didn't have
multi encoders yes we had the
possibility to bypass some encoders no
no no I'm asking a question a specific
question you've got net water feature
one goes to whatever right I'm asking
when you call that graph if you feed in
an association with that including that
net port you can send data directly into
that port correct or not correct if the
parties exposed yes even though we buy
exposed well how do you say how do you
say what does it mean to be exposed if
there is a multi-encoder attached to
that port then that sport is hidden
because look if you fed this port the
correct stuff the the framework wouldn't
principle allow you to feed things into
that port there's the point is that up
to now there was a complete equivalence
between having or not having in the
encoder what what's happening with this
proposal is that you have to confer the
net graph the summary box are both that
where you have the two inputs feed you
want to you two with the summary box
below or you just had food so fitti one
three two two becomes internal ports you
cannot access them anymore I understand
I mean although probably there should be
in the in this diagram here right yeah
but these missing fingers you cannot
send the directly stuff to one layer
which is in the middle of the
computation it becomes a is okay I don't
think we can okay but we could bypass
multi port also because you're talking
about bypassing them right if we provide
direct is output
okay but but I don't understand in this
setup
this is connectivity information for the
network here right and what you're
saying is this is another piece of
connectivity it's saying the thing
called foo which is external which I
understand why it isn't net port of foo
that's the convention we used to have
for single encoder like you attach a
single a a mono encoder
in that way like no I understand that I
understand but I'm saying that what will
be more consistent is to be able to put
and you can have an alighted syntax in
the case of a single encoder right that
you put that stuff into this
connectivity list here right you're
putting in foo
because here you're saying net port I
mean what I wouldn't suggest is net port
of foo goes to instead of directly to
one I don't understand this notation
here
what is that notation there mean sugar
you just say 1 goes to 3 and 2 goes to 3
and then you are wrapping them together
both 1 what is the two-level list net
port okay but but if I so that's a way
of representing a chain here is that
correct
exactly okay so here I don't understand
why I can't put this thing right in the
connectivity list here net port of foo
arrow multi-encoder arrow feature 1 and
feature 2 or this because we never had
this thing like encoders are not layers
in the framework they are property of
the port so if you put them in the
continuity graph we have to promote them
to be layer with all sort of changes but
also in the edge list if you look it's
this one and 2 is related to the list of
layers that is above but if you are
which is an object in the middle its
kind of really okay well fine so then
then then maybe there's a third argument
which is the encoder story
which says in Decorah right well which
one is the encoder I mean is do you have
to distinguish the encoders and decoders
we can infer them from the graph because
the encoder is a plug to an input and
decoder to an output it's in the list of
connectivity the left and thermal
encoders and when the protoss on the
right is a decoder okay yeah I
understand but the full form of this
would be net port of foo somehow goes to
multi-encoder goes to the list net port
of feature one and feature two I mean
you can elide that out but that's
basically what you're saying correct yes
I'm not sure on that bottle phooey
it depends on how we define a product
ready because fool comes from the real
world you know it can be any magic can
be anything but I mean when you feed in
look what's the difference between this
which is a net port that allows you to
feed stuff into the network and this
which looks to me an awful lot like a
net port don't ya know it's the same
except that as EULA was saying they were
together before like feature one is both
the name of the variable you give the
network and the name of the port after
the decoder they are the same name now
we're splitting that and so it's got a
definition of is the thing on the right
and on the left
both net or not what is a network what
is that is there a multiple argument
form of net port what
encoder what does it do it's it's used
to select ports of either layers or of
sub graphs with multiple parts so what
you're describing is what is one of the
proposal we were going through like to
have net port full comma feature one in
in the connectivity is that one of the
other proposals we were evaluating the
second proposal is net graph just
underneath this one alright it was just
their regions there
well I this yes yes exactly where you
have you don't necessarily have to
specify the output of in color and why
is that just the name of the encoder and
then the net port
Jiggs inside the encoder and it's like
oh I see here yeah you missing your big
you your moving part the entire
connectivity to the second argument for
me becoming closer to LA here it's like
this layin including color let's okay
alright I understand
so the third argue
the input and forth arguments the output
let the idea here of net causes the idea
was to keep the option like a step as
before no I don't think that's the right
thing to do I think it's crazy
I didn't they can simplify our program
yeah I'm sorry
it can simplify our problem if we change
this once simplify the issue we have
because we prefer the first proposal but
we had some issues because of this
option like surf there well I mean we
can just you know deprecated the option
like thing I mean we can continue to
make it work but all right so I mean so
this is saying there is an input
it's called foo it goes to this
multi-encoder which takes an association
with one element foo as its input and
produces an association with two
elements feature one and feature two is
its output is that correct no quite moot
encoder takes whatever it doesn't have
to take an association with a key named
foo it just takes the value of that
Association or what if that's more than
one input there what if foo is an
association I mean you you in that case
if you have to feed like two very
different data structures to that
encoder you will write the guts on the
encoder so that it expects a different
expression like all of these are about
function coders which are general
purpose encoders which you can you know
write the encoding function yourselves
yourself and and this is about extending
function encoders to multiple outputs
basically so it's already I understand I
understood all that I mean so well
really you can take whatever expression
he wants to two feet inside it's but
it's still treated as one part is one
thing you know this whole thing I mean
the correct thing to do here is whatever
strategy we're going to have for graphs
with labeled ports that's what we should
be using here and they're making sense I
mean this is a big hack yeah it's a big
mess and I don't know what the state of
of Charles and Roger and so on coming up
with ways to do ports for general graphs
do you know know what would it mean for
general graph well it means that you
have a know a vertex and a general graph
and it has three edges coming out of it
right those three edges right now it's
just like well one of the edges goes to
this node one of them goes to that node
and so on
um but now you could label those edges
you get what I'm saying edges a B and C
come out mmm an edge a goes to whatever
now we have edge labels but that's
different from essentially a whole
calculus of named of named ports right
and that's what we should be doing here
is this should not be net port this
should be some general way of
representing the you know because this
is essentially a node specification
right and this is some kind of
particular edge specification of a named
which is a named port we're making sense
look I think if
personal association this is I mean it's
a little bit contorted and messy but I
think that this is probably an okay way
to do this does that make sense to you
yes we require correspondence between
the strings that are coming out and the
output of the encoder like in principle
the encoder could give an association
with the keys a and B and we decide okay
you just want to name them feature one
if you two in this next picture and if
and if you leave out the right-hand side
here whatever it's naturally named
Association is from the from the encoder
this is basically just a convenience to
rename the outputs from the encoder so
that they can be fed into these net
ports yeah so there was a proposal that
I proposed on actually by Italian of
this which is too busy to do this
association thing but to have an option
for that so option would be like poor
settings or something like that it goes
to and then a giant list and that foo
goes to movie encoder can be one element
and then any number of settings setting
so you say net port settings is that
today you using yeah I don't actually
know I'm not sure about a name but yeah
stuff like that so that'll be a list and
that's you get a lot at least an
arbitrary length containing stuff like
that that's line above so foo goes to
multi-encoder goes to feature option to
comma bar goes to something else comma
another part in which you just attach
understand I understand I got it I got
it I gotta cut cut okay so I mean this
is real
net port in codings isn't it quite
because shapes for our array shapes for
the boards so it's not only about
encoding okay so what do you specify so
here let's say we say so give it a port
name like feature one right that's a
port no this is the total mess this is
the wrong way around yeah so if you want
to keep the port name on the left you
can do which was another one of the
proposals we evaluated which we
discarded it's because it wasn't it was
not option like but inside this you can
do it you can add list feature one
common feature two goes to multicolor
so that's you know you've got the ports
on the left and at the end I need you to
unscramble this okay this is too many
different alternatives what what are we
talking about here does this make sense
or is this waste of time feature one
feature - okay so look what you're doing
here is you you're saying this thing
this port you're calling foo which I
just don't understand why it isn't
called net port of foo because it is a
net board isn't it right yesyes okay so
why isn't it called net bought of foo as
it was it something yet more confusing
all the convention well it's wrong
because yeah because I'm so it use me
all I can option and it would be called
input most of the time like input goes
to in you put an encoder and output goes
to and you're fine you can you can but
we need to know what the full form of
the thing is and you can alight it
appropriately if you need to by making
sense yeah there's a now we're getting
out of the option we are more freedom to
put in export and so on well fine but I
mean I'm saying and then this guy
Anette port feature one feature - right
I mean you can elide the net port part
but it's basically should be that right
yeah so I don't understand if there's an
it this is an encoder hanging off the
end and you're always naming the outer
port beyond the encoder true or not true
previously you elided it and you simply
said that there was an encoder
associated with net port feature 1
correct right I mean you just had
something which says net bought feature
one happens to have an encoder
associated with it yes yes and yeah call
input but I ever said so so what you're
saying is that in the full form of it it
would be net port of input you know
arrow encoder arrow net port of feature
1 right that will be saying that
associated with feature 1 is this
encoder yes yeah okay so and you're
saying there are various elisions you
can make but what you need is to know
what the full form of this is supposed
to be now I'm very confused about what
the difference between that and the
connectivity information up here is
because if you put this if you put the
encoder information in this connectivity
list you know it's not a layer because
the layers are listed here I don't know
what this does for the net for a net
chain though this relevant to in that
chain or not relevant to pin that chain
this is how free of a mind and they
chained
is not clear way to name an input and an
output for the moment okay so so you
would just if you want to do this you
will use a net graph even though that
might be a trivial chain graph that
correct
chain you need at every day
it's a pipeline of software I'm aware so
I'm saying if you want to do these
things where you have but you can still
have an encoder at the beginning of a
net chain right yeah okay so I'm saying
here I don't understand why this is not
in the connectivity list do you get what
I'm saying yeah that's something I had
the same initial reaction to you
and but but this is my come so basically
is to make the encoder earlier it's not
a layer it's not a layer because in the
continuity list you don't have layers
you just have connectivity information
right the layers are in this analysis so
you wouldn't add an encoder in this
initial release that's correct I would
put it right you include that into the
connectivity list right as a special
connectivity thing right as a thing
where the connectivity now has an
encoder in there instead of just a two
for example
so there's three kinds of things that
come in here net ports indices and
encoders or decoders alright that will
be my proposal
and okay this is a non-trivial change
and I think we have to probably think
about the implications of this all right
okay that's my that's my suggestion I
mean you can always turn it into
something different you know by
evaluation or whatever else or whatever
you want to do but that's that would
seem to me to be the less least obscure
way to do this okay and I also would
suggest that you coulda lied this
notation to get rid of the net port
thing you just say quotes feature one
Harold whatever if you want to elide the
syntax here right what I'm saying right
yeah well that's yeah that's a good new
direction
I think might use something good all
right let's talk about okay again okay
or the various comments on our live
stream about complaints about things
crashing and memory leaks and so on I
don't know what those I mean I think one
needs to see specific examples of that
but do you guys have any comment on that
immediately
yeah we are Susan they fought to
stabilize the network like we we are
serving burgers every week they CIA
testing right we have testing for things
that are like our long training sessions
yes I mean we do application ourselves
on our move on our long and they say
resonate on kuku hugs is cookery
detection thing I don't know judo yes
okay so you must have trained something
like that on cocoa we we trained I mean
we we trained a lot of different
regressions and identification multi
hours even multi-day trainings okay so
but it doesn't crash for you what does
it crash for you no I mean it whenever
you crash during the development session
it was reported fixed okay
we need actual examples yes that could
be better even just the training script
would be enough right okay
what is this about should we look at
this right now or should we go under
ganz it's fast so this would and it has
consequence on again after so why not
okay so Dom you would say oh I say
so yeah the first idea was we need to
freeze layers like there are some for
example when you want to try the night
we had this to the same obscure in I
ResNet we wanted to add the epsilon time
identity to an array in the network but
this this epsilon you don't want to
learn it so you want to free stuff so
there are many examples of things but
what does that have to do with learning
right multipliers because that's the way
of freezing like you put it to zero none
and then you freeze the layer but
normally you have to give it to net
trained knowing where it is the layer
you have to freeze in the net cumbersome
because you know you have a big network
and you add a constant array somewhere
all right and you know this thing to
stay constant before in a trainer to say
learning rate ng players and indicating
exactly where this array is in this big
Network it's it's quite annoying it's
much better than at the couch and when
you construct the concentrate you say I
understand so your great multiplies it's
a bit of a weird thing to put I mean
would you ever have a value utter than
zero one here we will have minus one and
also yeah normally you want to freezer
you can choose value between zero and
one because it up to the network you
want it is the case that multipliers
isn't just being used as a hack to
switch things on and off with your own
one yeah at first I thought that there
will be it's by far my news like 99.99%
of time and then because of net gun and
it is true in transfer learning although
you would do it more than net trained
step rather than in the construction I
don't write to this so this seems fine I
mean I don't understand this one here
this seems very obscure oh I see that's
what does that mean exactly what how
would you do currently
to specify that you know so the left and
Damned in the ways of the first layer of
the mid that you give all right I think
this sounds like it could could change
don't have a problem with it okay cool
okay yeah that's a good news of very
good news is that we thought we might
not be able to do gun but actually we
can and with minimal change to the
design so Jim did some tests and talked
about it okay but basically bottom line
is we will be able to get cans for 12
one is that true yes if we agree with
this design and so Jerome did some
experiments which I guess you can press
the play button right you're on you can
play the animation here this is training
honest numbers so you has a sample that
every step of the training so one thing
you can look and we can use it later
is that you can see two dots function
here plus function of the two networks
but they are meaningless to tell if the
network is doing progress or not because
it's not about you cannot measure with a
loss function and how good is generator
it's just you know compared to each
other so you can know account it's in
equilibrium if it doesn't change but the
fact that it's down or up doesn't give
you information okay let me see the
basic way that you would set this up how
do you basically how do you basically do
again trading so it's actually will
realize we can do that with the same
designers what we are right now meaning
that net train still take only one
network as a first argument the only
thing we need to add is a way to specify
that a part of a network that's the
first thing you can see with a bit
interval the part of the network should
not be updated at every batch
so that's one thing we need and the
certain thing we need is to specify the
learning rate multipliers anywhere we
want and I think that's it right John
whether I thought that it again there
were two networks involved yes but we
can do it with only one network we
basically put a two network inside one
network it's not a good idea
well that's minimal design change almost
nothing that change and it's also very
clean because we we have added shortcuts
for for putting these two network in
Zwolle which is called net gun operator
which makes it very clear that you know
your your iraq you're doing you're doing
gun training okay but but i mean one
reason i like the idea of putting these
you know who knows whether we've got
sort of two-way ganz right now maybe in
the future there'll be seven wagons or
something yes and so that's a good
reason to not yes so that's so this is
quite specific indeed but as a general
saying before this is the minimal
[Music]
modification to the framework and we
already have a plan to a more general
thing so it involves basically so at
first it sounds like it doesn't have
anything to do but what it does which is
adding something which is called
reasonable training objects which
basically allows you to restart metric
all without the initial hopper ad which
is which is quite heavy pre-processing
and stuff by having that you can you can
get let several okay again basically
going low level so out of the trend so
so that's a big so the basic point there
is that you are doing
train is an overall rapper that just
does the whole training this resumable
net train object is stages of net train
in other words net train itself just
keeps running resumable that train
object until it gets to a fixed point
yeah in the second approach a single gun
training is several metric codes Naboo
and you don't have any training
monito for example so it's really going
low level which we expose at some point
so the big question is how much do we
start almost Erb do we put Internet
Train you know how much can we let me
try to understand what this is okay so
what the heck is this
what is updated while doing here so yeah
option that we need so it tells that the
generator isn't updated above some
completely different I mean that is used
in many many other functions did you for
a name is a name that Jerome came up
with as a string without even knowing
that option existed okay but why isn't
an interval this means every what does
this mean
five batch every five batch okay so
except is crazy we have to find
something else but this means there's a
part of the network that is called
generator is updated every five batch
you have sort of a clock right yeah
becomes one batch after one match and
every five the generator is updated and
for this criminal what we need to
specify is train I have three slash
accepts okay so fundamentally what
you're doing is you're saying that the
fundamental story if I just say D and G
is D D D D G exactly exactly that's
exactly I mean yeah right okay so we've
got various other patterns like that in
different places okay so what you're
saying is and what does
to refer to it wrapped in the del
operator for example oh no it will be a
named part of network so it's gonna be a
net network insider so how is it named
it was a net router how how is it named
it's a name of the layer it's a layer
basically but the layer is actually in
that graph and how do you lay that layer
in the framework how do you name a layer
you need to come when you construct you
in that graph is net graph for example
no I understand that but what what how
do you name the layer as in how do you
specify what that particular sub element
is called when you construct a network
you mean yes it's in the it's in the
first argument of net graph you have an
association I see I see I see I see so
that I see so so what you're saying is
net graph of and then you say you know D
goes to whatever it is D goes to its own
net graph yes and G goes to its own net
graph now what does it look like what is
the second argument look like on the
bottom of her net gainer with then graph
me where's net again what does net can
have to do with this so this would be
one way to easily construct this kind of
a little bit complex graph I'm sorry
where is the net can here just after
again after I mean that's the way you
can operate or you put a generator
discriminate or and loss function and
this would create a net graph basically
and you can see the net graph just just
there let's put construct and it is
what the hell is net in search arrays
yeah this is to share and network at two
different parts of the negraph but we
already have that yeah okay so the net
can operator sets up this kind of set up
is that the idea yes because it's a bit
complex I mean we could not have an
again operate on an operator but what
remind me about some of our other
operators net fold operator yeah need
for nests okay so when we have that okay
so net fold operator what does that is
this net gain operator directly
analogous to these things like that fold
operator in the sense that you've missed
a network of two networks in this case I
mean actually so it's a matter network
operator which is what this net counting
is yes it takes network as input and
give back another network seems sensible
to me I mean I don't know whether you
want to I would put the generator in
discriminator in analyst' there to have
the possibility of a future you know
multi gallery thing or is that so I
don't know it's it's a good ad cuz there
are cycle against with several delegates
oh okay fine and then then this is the
type of gann operator you're talking
about right and if you left that out
what's the default is there an obvious
default yeah sorry it's their loss so
this was a loss is that the loss where
it's the name of the last function here
okay this is the default which we can
say the type of gang kind of and we put
if
yes okay so now here in the net gun
operator why isn't this stuff inside the
net gun operator saying how many of this
versus how many of this right it could
be like cloning right meaty players
because the idea yeah to do the trees a
generator has to be a struggle running
race through minus one so we could do
the same trick with updates to hide
yeah because currently a bit interval
cannot go inside layer so if is inside
Miguel Prieto it would mean that alone
can go inside of a layer as well well
there's nothing I mean I don't know what
update in fullest because this is yes I
mean by the time you've got learning
rate multipliers going to zero means
don't ever learn on this layer I would
have thought that you could then it
would be meaningful for a given layer to
say you know update this layer train
this layer every five time steps or
something every five batches or whatever
hmm is that right I mean is that is that
the analogous thing that's very similar
to linear energy by or indeed we could
go this route but in practice you want
to experiment with this end for example
yes if you have to take five ten so
maybe you don't want to do it when you
define there well I understand but you
can still have net train default to
insert that look the basic point here is
that you know you're saying this is I
mean basically this is net update
schedule or something I think what it
roughly is is you know five steps of
generator followed by well one step of
generator followed by so this is like
what you would get from oh that's what's
it called um you know run length
encoding effectively I mean so this is
saying discriminator
four steps and then that would be right
so that would mean that cyclic list
thing now the alternative is you might
just put in there you know G D D D
whatever it is G blah blah blah blah
yeah well I think it's better with the
first proposal